I've said before that voting Donald
Trump out is only the beginning and the
analogy I used was that for the last
three and a half years we've essentially
been playing defense we haven't had the
ball we've been trying to get the ball
back if Donald Trump is removed by Joe
Biden and becomes the next president and
Joe Biden becomes the next president we
haven't scored we've just gotten the
ball back and that's when the fight will
will really begin and it's important to
flush this out a little bit now because
we're now only four months from the
election Donald Trump is becoming
increasingly unhinged there's really two
ways in which voting Trump out will only
be the beginning Trump out she achieves
no progressive policy like just removing
Trump doesn't give progressives any kind
of policy victory we will only get
progressive policy done if and when
Trump leaves if we demand it from
whoever is the next president be it Joe
Biden or be it someone else in 2024 the
removal of Trump is the start of the
possibility of progressive policy change
but it's not actually any policy change
so in that sense getting Trump out is
only the beginning and I've talked about
that before but there's another side to
this which is really ugly and we have to
sort of come to terms with even if you
remove Donald Trump
you've not removed trumpism trumpism is
a virus that is going to be around for a
while and by trumpism I'm talking about
all of the really ugly stuff that we've
seen for years now the legacy of
nepotism and corruption and the
normalization of that in government the
mainstreaming of racism and xenophobia
that existed before Trump but it wasn't
so brazenly out in public that's one of
the things that Trump has done he's
coalesced and sort of said to the
xenophobes and racists come back out
into the public come back out you're
welcome now a ton of the behavior that
people felt ashamed about before and
would keep behind closed doors now it's
become almost glorified in some sense
that won't go away the day Trump is
removed the core singing of language as
I call it you know grab them by the
you-know-what making fun of people with
disabilities tweeting white power videos
I could go on and on and on with dozens
examples that's not going to go away
when Donald Trump leaves office and in
fact it could actually get worse if
Donald Trump loses and claims that it
was rigged we might see the absolute
worst of it come out with guns to
protest an election that Donald Trump
may use to convince his followers that
it was actually rigged against him so if
we see that type of violence it could
get worse before it actually gets better
and then what about Republicans we also
have to deal with the Republicans in the
House and Senate who have been gleefully
cheering Trump some of them others have
stood aside and allowed trumpism
to take hold and run rampant and I'm
thinking of people like Susan Collins
who's perpetually perpetually
disappointed with Trump but doesn't
actually do anything about it and
arguably the enablers are just as bad as
the cheerleaders none of that will be
removed just because Donald Trump is
removed in November so the point here is
not to put the cart before the horse and
pretend Biden's got this thing in the
bag we have won nothing yet we're still
trying to get the ball back
by removing Donald Trump in November if
and when that happens it could be this
November it could be November of 2024
that Trump leaves first of all we may
have to bear the brunt of a short period
of even more chaos and violence in the
streets from people who will simply
refuse to believe that Donald Trump lost
if indeed he loses in November but then
we've got to look at the Senate we have
to look at the house we have to look at
governor's and we have to look at the
culture that has been created to the
culture of Trump ISM and this is why I
keep talking about we get to vote in
multiple elections in November we get to
vote for Joe Biden but if you're in
Arizona you also get to vote for Mark
Kelly to replace martha mcsalley if
you're in montana you get to vote for
Joe Biden but you also can vote for
Steve Bullock to be elected senator Amy
McGrath in Kentucky all of these other
options where we can replace senators
who have either been actually supporting
Trump or standing aside and not getting
in Trump's way they are all part of the
problem and then when you look at
specific issues you really I mean it's
hard not to be pessimistic you realize
what we are up against if we
remove Trump in November we will have
lost four years when it comes to the
environment and to climate we can't get
those years back and so what that means
is that we're going to have to go above
and beyond even what we thought we would
have to deal with to handle the
destruction that Donald Trump has done
and I will go even further if even if
Joe Biden defeats Donald Trump in
November we are going to have trumpets
type candidates at least in 2020 to try
to get in possibly in 2024 so we're
going to have multiple election cycles
during which we will have to resist
these malignancies so that we can try to
end the national nightmare that is
trumpism so again let's not put the cart
before the horse your job is to envision
that when you go to vote in November
your vote could be the difference maker
between Trump wins your state and Biden
wins your state mathematically it's very
unlikely to come down to one vote but if
we all have that mentality none of us
will stay home we will all go out and
vote that's number one we don't put the
cart before the horse but remember that
you might also be voting on a Senate
race and if the right thing were to
happen in November then and only then
will we be able to say now the work
starts now we spend the transition
period figuring out how will we make
Biden as left as possible how will we
hold Biden accountable to the
concessions and there have been some
that he's made to the more progressive
wing of the Democratic Party that's
where it all starts and it's going to be
a very very long battle so you know last
week or the week before I got a phone
call from a viewer saying you know isn't
the Senate really more important because
even if we remove Biden but we don't
have the Senate we can't do that much
it's all important we get to vote for
president and we get to vote for senator
in some states of 35 races and we get to
vote for House of Representatives and
some governors and some state reps and
states that it all matters it's not one
or the other it's we should all
participate and we are going to have to
resist this viral virus
trumpism not only at every level in
November but likely for a few election
cycles to come and that is why I we just
have to keep the pressure up on all
aspects of this we have to keep the
pressure up from the perspective of
voter suppression we have to keep the
pressure up when it comes to the the TV
ads we have to keep the pressure up when
with these other online groups that are
putting together really good videos
targeting Trump we don't know what it is
that will make a difference when we look
back at 2016 was it commis second press
briefing about hillary was it Russian
social media campaigns was it Hillary
not visiting Wisconsin towards the end
of the there's you will never know the
one thing and when you have such a
complex election with 300 in a country
of 330 million about a hundred and
twenty hundred and thirty million votes
no one thing is ever going to be
definitively the difference-maker these
are all parts and that's why it's so
important we have a fantastic program
coming up for you today
later on I want to address this question
of how is Biden's lead today different
than Hillary's lead in 2016
nothing is a foregone conclusion but
there are some important differences
between the polling today and the
polling in 2016 and we're going to talk
about them we also are going to talk
about what will the debates between
Trump and Biden look like I know that
there are people convinced that one or
the other is going to absolutely implode
during the debates I'm not so sure we
are going to talk about that later today
and I also am going to dig into I
previewed this earlier in the week
how does Justice John Roberts fit in
ideologically compared to the people
Donald Trump has put on the Supreme
Court we're going to talk about the daka
decision the LGBT decision and the
abortion decision all of that coming up
today plus your phone calls make sure
you're following me on instagram at D
Pakman and make sure you are subscribed
for free to the daily audio podcast on
whichever is your favorite podcasting
platform
Spotify iTunes Google Play stitcher your
pick were on all of them
this episode is sponsored by blue Chu
one of the things I make a priority on
the show is not to perpetuate stigma for
things that don't deserve it we've
talked about mental health we've talked
about many things where we should all
just be respectful adults period and we
would be better off and blue Tru can
increase performance and give you that
extra confidence you may be looking for
blue to calm blue like the color blue is
the first chewable with the same
fda-approved ingredient as in Viagra and
Cialis it can be taken day or night even
on a full stomach since it's chewable it
works twice as fast as a pill whenever
the opportunity arises blue chew is
prescribed online by licensed doctors
you don't have to go to a doctor's
office you don't have to wait in line at
a pharmacy it ships right to your door
in a discreet package they're made in
the USA and since blue two prepares and
ships direct it's cheaper than a
pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue Cho
comm get your first shipment free when
you use our promo code Pakman that's PA
que ma n pages $5 shipping that's blue2
dot-com promo code Pakman to try it
totally free blue chew is the better
cheaper faster choice and we thank them
for sponsoring the David Pakman show